الرئيس الاوكراني فلو ميرسي يزور الجاره
الحليفه بولندا ويلتقي رئيسها الذي اكد
خلال مؤتمرنا صحفي عقده مع نظيره
الاوكراني ان بلاده ارسلت حتى الان ثمان
طائرات ميك تسعه وعشرون الى اوكرانيا
وانها سترسل ست طائرات اخرى في المستقبل
القريب وهي مستعده لتسليم كامله اسطولها
اي 30 طائره من هذه المقاتلات السوفيتيه
الصنع اذا اتفق الحلفاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي على ذلك نحاول في قمه الناتو
المقبله التي ستعقد في صيف هذه السنه
تحقيق ضمانات امنيه اضافيه من شانها تعزيز
الامكانيات العسكريه الاوكرانيه وان تقوي
الشعور بالامن لدى الاوكرانيين ومن شانها
ايضا ان تشكل دعما معنويا مهما جدا للروح
الدفاعيه لدى المقاتلين في اوكرانيا ضد
المعتدي الروسي اعتقد حقا ان مثل هذه
الضمانات ستكون البدايه اكرر البدايه
لعضويه اوكرانيا المستقبليه بالكامل ضمن
حلف شمال الاطلسي
الذي ركز على الوضع الميداني في بلادها
وخاصه في بخموت شكر شريكه البولندي على
دعمه الثابت لدخول اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما شكر البولنديين على
استقبالهم لملايين اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
مذكرا بان المعركه التي يخوضها رجاله ليست
دفاعا عن اوكرانيا فقط وانما دفاعا عن
اوروبا كلها نحن حريصون جدا ان تلعب
بولندا دورا مهما في عمليه اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا ليس على مستوى الدوله فقط نحن
مهتمون جدا بالاعمال المستقبليه لدينا
العديد من المشاريع المختلفه واعلم ان
لديكم الكثير من الشركات المستعده للعمل
في اوكرانيا تملك الخبره والرغبه والافراد
والموظفين والمال تاتي زياره زيلينسكي الى
وارسو في وقت يتوقع فيه ان تشن قواته في
الاسابيع او الاشهر المقبله هجوما مضادا
لاستعاده السيطره على مناطق في جنوب
البلاد وشرقها وتحضيرها من القوات الروسيه